welcome back to CBS mornings where for
months now we've been showing you
pictures pictures like these from inside
Ukraine where the Russian military is
using iranian-made drones that Target
civilian areas causing immense damage to
homes also infrastructure well now for
the first time we are seeing how these
and other drones depend on computer
parts made in other countries including
the U.S and as Chris livesay shows us
from Ukraine it is proving very
difficult for the West at large to stop
the technology from getting into Russian
hands
they Menace Ukraine Skies killing
hundreds and scarring Millions but while
the drones are Russian and Iranian key
technology is European and American the
Ukrainian government showed us photos of
components produced by U.S companies
Maxim and microchip retrieved from
Russian and Russian modified Iranian
drones so what are we looking at here so
this is Orlean 10 it is a basic Russian
UAV Ukrainian drone specialist Pablo
Castro shows us the chip inside the logo
reads you blocks a Swiss company so
without this ship no the plane doesn't
know where to fly the same kind of chips
are found inside smartphones tablets
cars potentially anything used with
satellite navigation but in Ukraine
Russia is using them to tap into glonass
moscow's answer to GPS
Ukrainian lawmaker yarislav yarushin
says at least six American and companies
produce glow Nets compatible ships
microchip technology Chandler Arizona
that's my hometown so to be clear
civilians are being killed yes and what
we can do we can stop to
sell these chips none of the American
companies agreed to an interview or
would answer whether they do business in
Russia u-blocks the maker of the Swiss
chip we saw says they cut ties with
Russian companies at the start of the
war we just want wanted to avoid doing
any kind of business in uh in this
region but CBS has seen recent Customs
forms that show components from the U.S
and Europe are still making it into
Russia Today through distributors in
third-party countries the microchips are
going indirectly to Russia through China
through Malaysia and other third
countries are you saying that countries
like China are laundering this
technology for Russia of course yeah the
companies argue it's intended for
civilians but that doesn't stop Russia
from using it to kill is it possible to
create these components but to make them
incompatible with glonass
I think I believe in theory yes Ukraine
says that if you make these components
incompatible with glowness you will save
lives is that something your company is
willing to do
um that's at least something we're going
to consider and discuss internally
for now the killing continues
if those companies were in this room
what would you tell them I want to ask
if they really want to see their logos
here that is the question for CBS
mornings Chris lives say Kiev
this is such an important investigation
and keep in mind that Chris livesay and
his team Aaron Lyle his producer we're
doing this within a war while war was
going on around them I can't help but
think of other companies this could be a
wake-up call for them because
soldiers on both sides have phones Apple
phones Samsung phones in their pockets
that are helping them yeah with you know
strategy and GPS yeah and they don't
want to see their logo uh being used in
a war zone but at the same time I don't
know what the solution is it's a hard
question yeah you're right about that